august fand sie machen alle mit
ja richtig coole leute finde ich echt
geil von euch
erst jetzt und die wurde direkt los
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge handycam jason kenney personen
dieser event kollege neben mir und
zwangsweise im zusammenarbeit
er hat gedacht handicap komplett ohne
rüstung ist mir so das ganze vergessen
bruder handicap du darfst nur
brustpanzer anziehen
ich habe vorgeschlagen dass es im qs
gemacht aber die challenge hat er dann
nicht accepted weil ist natürlich noch
mal eine nummer härter die schuhe und so
kann es nicht direkt wegwerfen wollte
irgendwo anders ticken und da hab ich
gesagt also nur nur brust platte was
schon echt hart ist ich meine wenn
jemand vor dir steht mit vollgas gibt
brustpanzer zweieinhalb maximal drei
eisen war gut dabei hilft ja ich will
das eigentlich ungefähr schafft dem
maximum eines rüstungs niveaus
angekommen das heißt natürlich die
kämpfe werden extrem spannend weil ich
mich sehr sehr gut drauf konzentrieren
muss möglich wenn ich jetzt zu bekommen
also auf jeden fall in bogen wenig
verhält wenn ich falsch und so dass dem
wichtig schwärmen in holzschwert ist
jetzt auch noch nicht die sache safe
würde ich mal sagen aus wird auf jeden
fall recht und bogen um eine feine floss
aber auch auf die stars camp wird
wahrscheinlich eine möglichkeit sein
es wurde dem finger ausnutzen irgendwie
so indem er total rat im auftaktspiel
weg lauft und dann schöner machen
das wird wohl die devise sein ich gehe
hier wieder mal eine stadt die route die
meisten hatte wenn ich schon kennen hier
durch diesen komischen tunnel gibt es
meistens relativ viele kisten an dessen
relativ wenig leute da wenn meine da ist
dann ist das eine kleine ruheinseln
klatschen kann also gar kein problem
weil ich anders gemeint ist diese schöne
rüsten die nie anziehen darf man aber
ist eine andere wäre auch nicht falsch
weil diese anträge liebt den ja so ne
wenn du leute einfach zurück angst und
dann wenn und tnt platziert wie op tnt
die leute sind direkt hinter die
der ist ja warum und spams die angel auf
die dass die ins der tnt gepustet werden
funktioniert dass oftmals schon oft auch
immer das reicht von raul
er fährt sehr gut hat das einfach so als
pvp tricks selbst erfunden ja ja und das
funktioniert so gut dass auch ein radar
den brauch nehmen und was essen
das passiert mir mega oft dass ich
einfach viel zu schnell wächst ständig
sachen gegessen ab heute bei anderen pc
den dem festivalmotto immer schnell mal
sex oder ja ja natürlich ich mein ich
bin bekannt dafür zu hacken hier warum
warum hast du eigentlich nicht an deinem
pc aufgenommen wohl weil wird er drauf
hacks hab mich darauf mich spielen
wollte feld laufen spielens nur beide
darauf hexers tsg cross up close and
noble geworden als sex habe ich jetzt
aber ich weiß nicht jeder weg macht
sonst bei dem ein anschleichen oder wir
warten wie man die kiste wenn es nicht
aber das problem daran eingestellt war
sie darüber was der 2012 ansteht hat
dessen 29 städte nicht
rom - rom rp oder durch den bunten
decken ich will da unten
ich kann ich kann den meisten pleiten
okay leute mache jetzt volles risiko
wir gehen auf den tipp kollegen da unten
wir greifen an hoffe mal sieht uns nicht
kommen hoffen wir er hat keine gute
rüstung
er kann ja gerne irgendwie ein stein
stellte aber er darf einfach kein so
krasses rüstungs vorteil
das nicht essen versieht
schön wäre es sehr gut läuft es hat
funktioniert und wir können es in
eisenstadt machen und wie am 18
ich wollte hat den helm anziehen das
darf ich leider heute nicht und ich
dachte das wäre
und wirklich logo be kannt direktes das
schwert verzaubern gehen also würde ich
jetzt echt ich will kein risiko eingehen
auf dem weg zum schwert server ich
während ich renne ich renne deutlich
erschwert ist wo zirka alles was du
weisst du kriegen kannst alles was in
dieser runde haben kann ich habe jetzt
den meisten bogen
da kann ich eigentlich zum reisen man
soll immer zu mir auf reisen schwerter
kriegt man nie was gutes selten ganz
selten mal kriegt meistens irgendwie
noch berg oder so hin weil ich habe hier
meinen screenshot chance die extra für
dich gemacht
ab level eintrafen und noch mehr
schaffen es und nach weg das ist echt
selten also mit gutes mache ich das
nochmal schaffen es drauf bekommt das
ist echt schon nicht oft also ich würde
sagen so sieben von zehn verzauberung
zumindest in survival games ich habe
eine andere das ist zweifellos anders
ist als die kräfte natürlich habe es
einfach dass es in ender games
beispielsweise anders als zb games ich
glaube in zweifel games ca sieben von
zehn sind nichts scharfes hier ist der
beweis bei daparto potts vielen dank
minecraft und da sind ihm und gibt und
der rüstung
er kommt bist du dich neu im team
anschließend selber backstage
gerne okay machen die rüstung geben nein
machen die leute jobs geht es gut der
ist richtig gut ja heute nicht ich habe
schon eins gegen eins mit ihm gemacht
338 der dass dessen schlechter ok ok ok
wat wir fragen dagegen müssen schnell
was schreib oder erzählt aus fünf mach
dann ziel du aus hauptsache du machst du
schnell warum
und weil wir jetzt natürlich nicht mehr
umstimmen ok alles klappt wird sie dann
den rest ok alles klar
21 32
aber der typ macht ihren job seine
kamera auch nicht dass die direkt nicht
das was macht er was macht ihr das macht
ja okay wenn direkt sehr gut klappt hier
die noch oder soweit war echt nett dass
er dass er das gemacht
sehr cool damit haben wir nicht
gerechnet so fair sind unsere change und
unsere change sozusagen annehmen er
kennt aber auch die cave emery also das
kann sein wenn es auf jeden fall eisen
brustpanzer und es geht weiter
seinen kollegen dürfen jetzt direkt
retten würde ich mal dass man auf ein
halbes leben keine rüstung nur den eisen
brustpanzer aber das ist die challenge
leute aber ich habe gegen den aufsteiger
kämpft im bett management ich sag dir
auf den nahkampf ist ja echt krass
partie richtig statt
denn das ist das schlimmste ich habe vor
jahren im inventar und ich kann es
einfach nicht ausspielen ich kann den
trumpf ausspielen du auch wenn wir leute
seid ihr dabei seid ihr nicht dabei bist
du dabei erwischte dabei den challenge
nur bus die schreiblust die auch nur
größten wert ist gedacht leute
vielleicht können wir vielleicht
gewinnen wir tatsächlich mit der
brustpanzer challenge wer hätte das
gedacht okay ich verlasse mich jetzt
einfach mal auf meine bogen skills
dreier ins co seit wann ist denn der
chat zu gedrosselt oder ist das nur bei
youtuber nicht
cockpit bin oder so fragt das natürlich
scheiße arendt warum schreibt warum
schreibst du rennt com weiterziehen
restitution aus die größer ausfielen
jetzt natürlich was soll ich sonst war
ich sehr spannend gibt ihm wird wie viel
hast du eigentlich
naja gut sehr gut sehr gut wir haben's
geschafft heute gg ich möchte erstmal
das ganze gut mit ihr oder die golden
goal der ist wichtig wichtiger goldie
aber spanien führt match das ist ja bei
mir auf jeden fall fürs match ja oder
oder auf reinhardt auf reinigt das von
euren krieg gegeben
um kurz vor 3 sekunden oder zwei
sekunden musste den goldabbau essen hast
du mit wurde der andere wo ist die
andere dieser arrays hat sich als sehr
fair gespielt grüßen dich
das war sehr gut von der finde ich sehr
korrekt kenne ich nicht wie man können
wir machen später verloren wenn
überhaupt auf astro gehört gerade und
das rtl bogen hingekriegt den der ich
weiß aus der markt ich weiß was der
macht wetten dass liegt sich jetzt
gleich was hat dir vor ich lasse mich
jetzt nicht runter haben das hier das
ist hier ich nicht dass wir die das ist
mir die ganze sache nicht werde das
tempo ist in 15 sekunden
okay okay ich hab den ball dafür
rechtzeitig jetzt goldabschnitt goldie
reihen 321 regeneration läuft
hoffentlich die kleine map ja sehr gut
okay okay alles klar
sie machen alle mit ja richtig coole
leute finde ich echt geil von euch
schwer dickes dickes plus an die
community halten auf jeden fall unia
community zwei teile beider feste 10 tmg
und angel
das stimmt das stimmt alles klar hast du
ein effizientes
und die die herzen sind auch weg dass es
irgendwie immer so vermittelt wird und
die kommen dann wieder oder sowas
das kribbelt es hier aber nur teile er
so ich habe keine legale komm wir machen
er ist in der aufnahme ok jetzt jetzt
müsste es eigentlich holen oder von
chat- dann seine stats fortschicken kd
dem supplier also leute fand sich gegen
gefährliche keine ahnung
da nimmt es mir nicht übel wie auch
schon die ganze zeit mangelt ihr nennen
hätte das ist so ein mensch der brauch
keinen bogen
ihr macht irgendwelche komischen tricks
wtf was ist das denn
ein guter trick
jolo rolf was für ein double dip naja
yang jiechi leuchtet das war auf jeden
fall der relativen leistet geld hat gut
mitgespielt coole sache finde ich aber
falls sie ideen hat für weitere channels
könnte die gerne die kommentare
schreiben
und natürlich ein leichter lassen sich
gefallen hat ob ich werde ganz jetzt so
ein bisschen hinterm mikro ihr aber er
hat etliche bist versteckt er sowieso
schon ein bisschen verspielt und
schicken und schüchtern auf jeden fall
ist manchmal videos schneiden na ja die
leute es ist ein uhr nachts und wir
nehmen es auch für euch ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen
haut rein macht bis zur nächsten folge
und